vine malama on va voir ton clip c'est a
repris jardin d'hiver popularisé par an
exactement
ces premiers extraits de cet album
jardin d'hiver tirée la chanson avec je
me laisserais mieux laisse ses grands
talents qui a remis en selle d'ailleurs
henri salvador
ouais ouais c'est vrai c'est parti
genève
l'homme
le
[Musique]
tendresse
si je
seul
[Musique]
là
elle
temps
tout
alors il ya un jardin d'hiver
heinz aux gaines genres que j'adore
pocket et basse ah oui oui mais toi tu
manges du pied janet était vaste
pourquoi que tu mange du porc pourquoi
tu manges durera louve quoi c'est parce
que c'est bon le bacon il est où le
problème
tu as raison fais toi plaisir vous avez
tous eu droit durant les mois je vois là
moi j'ai arrêté pour des raisons je mets
un combat bien entendu même faites ce
que vous voulez quoi tu veux manger un
sandwich au bacon tu te le péché pas de
faire chier mais tbg tanière je m'en
tape aussi lire du moins voilà y
apporter masse il ya la vie en rose que
tu reprends adieu mon amour j'ai demandé
à tirer non mais c'est vrai car près
c'est vrai une foule dense haye et nilda
fernandez aussi magnifique vous voulez
jamais sa bosse et des inédits ou alors
oui je te rappelle qu'henri sur rfm et
nous on s'est vus vous avez fait sur bfm
radio
ah oui mais juste avant miss france a
way et je me rappelle y était allé tout
de suite une nouveauté rfm georges
brassens le mulot cool
il a dit qu on alors bye malama alors
que tu as bad mama tu vas te concert
fond dans la musique parce que je pense
que ça va marquer le moment parce qu'en
fait quand je fais quelque chose j'aime
vraiment ça afin de truquer mais je
pense maintenant que c'est terminé bien
je peux être vers manama
la tâche prête et fiat de partage
aujourd'hui c'est vaima l'adra
interprète ses plus miss france où te
fout il échappe pas même pour tous
courir tu leur dis colonies s imagine si
je tombe malade en tant que je peux pas
malama est ce que tu t'es servi de muse
france dès le départ tu t'es dit voilà
je vais essayer d'être connue pour
pouvoir faire de la chanson après ou pas
du tout ça lui en étant me seront non
c'est venu à appeler mais ce que j'ai
toujours aimé chanter même toi tu m'as
fait chanter si c'est vrai sa maman
oui eh ouais ça leurs familles et toute
attente avons aussi je m'attends à
chanter dans la douche quoique moment on
en a chanté plein on a repris nos achats
nightwing que tu fais quoi là ça dépend
laquelle tu veux pas c'est que tu as
chanté que tu as un style de vie à léona
ji
emma watson belime à la main en tout cas
je te dis on a beaucoup aimé l'album je
vous jure que c'est vrai c'est ça
d'aiton savoie
moi j'ai pris là c'est plus je l'aimé
parce que c'est un j'ai pris comme ça à
gvt est loin du truc j'ai pris comme ça
sherine j'étais dans la dans la r 19 g
l'autoreverse mais comme j'ai fait comme
ça paris montpellier serait j'ai écouté
toutes les chansons je suis arrivé
j'avais une boule au ventre
j'avais une boule ronde je suis sorti
j'avais une boule dans le coeur aha
[Applaudissements]